From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today is Wednesday, April 27, 2011. We're in Atlanta, Georgia, the Artmore Hotel, with Ms. Jamila Jones,
to conduct an oral history for the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture project entitled The Civil Rights History Project.
My name is Joe Mosnier of the Southern oral history program at UNC Chapel Hill and our videographer is Mr. John Bishop.
Ms. Jones, good morning. Thanks so much for sitting there.
Thank you for having me.
Appreciate your effort to get up with us during this Atlanta visit. It's really nice to see you. Thank you.
Let me start today as we enter into a conversation about your work and Southern freedom movement in the 50s, 60s and even thereafter.
Talk a little bit about your family, start with a little bit about growing up in Montgomery and your family, your parents.
Okay, I live with a mother and a grandmother. I grew up with a sibling, my sister, Dars, Khrinshaw, and a brother, a little younger, about 10 years younger, John, Alan McQuirell.
And I guess key to the movement is the fact that my sister and I rode the Montgomery bus line.
So we experienced on a daily basis during school the harassment that came from the bus driver.
And so I guess that inspired us or it was something in us that made us relate to, of course, the Montgomery Bus Boycott.
Can you talk a little bit about how you came to know Ms. Parks and to join the Youth Chapter of the Logon ACP?
Yes, in fact, my sister was the one who introduced me to Mrs. Rosa Parks as we joined the NAACP Youth Council and NACP Youth Group.
My sister was vice president. I was just a member of that group. She would have us into her home.
We would sit on the floor and she'd give us bits and pieces about life, actually.
And people asked quite often, if I remember things that she said and I do not, but I know she read from papers from the National Office of the NAACP.
And she taught us that we were important. I can remember that.
And that it was key that we learned our rights and that voting was an important aspect of our lives.
And I can just remember those things about the conversations that she had with us.
And she also taught us that it was important to carry yourself in a good, responsible way.
After we were meet, she would give us Kool-Aid and Kool-Aid.
Dr. Joe Kool-Aid was from SIRM.
Ms. Jones, you mentioned your sister, Doris Ketchock. Can you talk a little bit about her? You mentioned she was vice president and just described her a little bit.
Yes, she was like a leader of the bunch. And whatever she did, basically I did.
There was a difference in us and that I was mostly interested in the music portion of things that happened.
And she was more of the leadership fighter type movement person.
But she somehow had interest from a very young age in rights and what was right for you.
And she let me down that path.
So you must have been about 11 years old when the boy cut began.
How was he 11 years old when the boy cut stopped?
What are some of your, you know, from this distance? What are your some of your most, most central, important memories from that experience?
From that experience, I know that the youth, and this is not often said, had their own kind of individual movement, that we let ourselves around what was happening with the movement.
And that we organized ourselves to get across what we call a cross town when we were no longer riding the buses.
And we had to find our own way for survival.
My sister being the leader that she was wouldn't allow us ever to go and get a ride.
She said, we'd be taking a space from an adult and we were going to walk.
So the 381 days, we walked.
When the boy cut concluded and some measure of success was realized in some measure on that narrow question of buzzing.
What was your feeling?
It was a joyous feeling of course.
And no longer we felt that we had to take the abuse.
That we had experienced on those buses since I was six years old.
Because I started to ride the bus at age six and had done that to age 11.
And we found always to survive through that.
It was piercing to see adults have to leave the bus and go around to pay their money and then get off the bus and come to the back of the bus.
I almost never had to do that because we were the first stop.
So we always found ourselves with a seat.
But curious as we were, there were times we tested to see what would happen if we sat in the front of the bus.
And we did.
And then they would ask us of course, when one white lady got on the bus I can never forget her.
She had read her long hair.
And when she entered the bus we would have to get up even though there were a number of seats and she was the only white to get on that bus.
So I think there was so piercing to us that it never, I never forgot it.
And when the bus boy caught started of course that lived within me.
And I knew that I would walk 300 no hell.
However many days actually that it would take.
And to a six-year-old you just basically had so curious about why is it that we have to get up.
That often I would sit behind her.
And she would choose the same seat each time she got on the bus.
And this white woman, I don't know her name, I just remember her face and her red hair.
But when she got on the bus I decided several times to just feel her hair.
See if I could put my little fingers on the top of the seat to see if it was a difference.
What is the difference with her and the rest of us.
And I did. I would just kind of feel that hair like it was an accident.
I don't know what I concluded from that.
Except that it just gave me a feeling that I feel she's really no different.
This hair is not so much different from ours.
And that was just my little child who would curiosity and how I answered it.
So that just that one white lady puts such curiosity in me.
And I wanted to answer that so much that I knew that I was going to walk the length of the time
and take for us to get to our goal.
When and how did you start singing?
Started singing. We were elementary school students at Alabama State Laboratory High School.
And each Friday we would have a I would call it a talent show.
And we formed this group, three girls, and she was four of us from the beginning.
Form this group so that we couldn't compete each Friday in the talent contest.
Somehow it was something in us that made us want to do freedom songs.
And I can't answer today why we chose that because we're about the same age as Diana Ross.
But when we went outside to practice, we practiced freedom songs.
And that's what we would sing.
So when the Montgomery Bus Boycott came, we formed this group at around the age of 19.
We were kind of ready.
And so because of the songs we were singing, it led itself to the movement.
We were asked to come to sing at practically every tea that was held in Montgomery.
You know during that time they had a lot of teas that raised money for the movement
as well as other things for the churches.
And they would invite us to come.
And I felt like it couldn't be a tea.
Or they felt like they couldn't have a tea if we didn't come.
So we went all over town to teas on Sunday to participate.
And we were kind of carrying the message of the movement through our songs.
And we were relevant for the time.
And that's why they called on us.
And it was a group of four girls all 11 and 12 years old I guess.
We were in that moment.
Do you remember the names of the other girls?
I do.
It was Gladys Carter.
Because we formed the group and we all through high school, we kept the group.
Gladys Carter and many Hendrix now McCans.
We were three girls who lasted among the four.
We decided we were going to not only practice at school, but we would practice at each other's homes.
And that's how the fourth girl dropped out because her parents wouldn't allow her to come each evening.
Or the evenings that we had set for practice.
And thus it became the fourth.
Did you all say singing church?
We did.
We were singing church.
But mostly we sang at school at first because we all went to different churches.
Which was in church?
Mine was Mount Zion AME Zion Church.
Was any of the other girls at Reverend King's church?
None of us were members of Reverend King's church.
Many McCans was a member of Reverend Abernathy's church.
I was with Reving Sey, Sey, who was...
had the first meeting for the Montgomery Bus Boycott.
And he was very active.
As a matter of fact, the things in your life that caused you to...
I guess these some total of things caused you to be what?
Whatever you are in life.
And he talked each Sunday about accomplishments they had made to what needs of the black community.
And I would hear what he had to say.
So that was one of the influences that I had in terms of my life and fighting for freedom of struggle.
Yeah.
Let's see, you must have entered high school around 57, 50, fall of 57, fall of 58.
Yeah, I finished in 62.
And can you describe the...
I think the late 50s, because at some point, if...
I've read a couple different accounts, but one indicates that you traveled to Highlander Book School.
I did.
But that was before high school, it was like junior high school, I think, well.
But I was singing along with my sister being very active.
We were selected to go to do a kind of a cultural exchange in terms of our music.
We would share the kind of songs that we would sing and got carried away.
I headed up that...
The workshops.
And people from around the world, actually, because we met people from Africa there,
would share the kind of movement songs they were doing.
It was because our repertoire of songs, of freedom songs, were great and extensive
that we come to New York to do freedom songs, to raise money,
to raise money, to raise money, to raise money, to raise money, to raise money.
And that's how we got to kind of get home with Reverend Sheldon's work and others to do that fundraiser.
And from that came one of the first albums of civil rights songs to be used for fundraising and that kind of thing.
We were the Montgomery Gospel Trio.
We did not have a name.
We went all over Montgomery before that time.
Never thought about a name.
They would just say the girls.
We got to have the girls or the girls this.
And when we got there, they said, for this album, you got to have a name.
And we debated and debate about what could be our name and came up with the Montgomery Gospel Trio.
How long have you been at that time when you went to New York?
I want to say, you know, around 16.
Just in high school.
Yes.
Can you talk me through your high school years because obviously the movement will shift and go very active days while you were in high school?
The Freedom Riders will come into being toward the end of your high school years.
So I'm interested in how you move through those years singing, protesting as an active event.
Yes. And what happened is that Montgomery, when you have a large scale movement like that, quite often, there are a lot of wounds that occur.
So, Montgomery, particularly the adults, could not sit down sometimes in the same room, let alone talk about a movement.
And so the youth will use.
So when James Bevel and all the people came into Montgomery and by the way we did meet James Bevel and Bernard LaFayette Jr Jr,
well, the other group that came to do the concert at Carnegie Hall, so we had already met them.
But they came into Montgomery first with the Freedom Riders.
And so because we knew them, we had gone to Reverend Ralph Abernathy's house and waiting to get the youth to go pick up the Freedom Riders as they came in because at the time we still active in movement and still singing.
And Mrs. Juanita Abernathy said, we don't have anybody to pick them up.
Now, a lot of adults will tell you that they did, but that day we stole a car. We said, well, we got to go find a way to get the Freedom Riders.
And there was a girl, her name was Antoinette Carson, and she had her license at the time.
And her grandfather would leave his car in the garage every day.
So we skinned together and said, we were going to steal his car and go pick up the Freedom Riders.
And we did, it was how and the real, we're going to get this car back in here.
So what we did was we took some school chalk and mark where the tires of his car were.
And took the car, picked up the Freedom Riders, went back and put that car right in the tracks of those marks that we had made.
And it was such an eventful day to see how they were beaten and how they were treated when getting off of those buses.
And we had a car load up when we left.
Were you yourself ever so close to violence that you really feel feared for your own personal safety?
It's something about youth that even when you have fear, and it's something about having lived that kind of life,
that your fear is bundled and it's there.
But it does not outweigh the need to participate.
So that there were times when we feared, we had fear.
In fact, the night that the Freedom Riders came in, we went to the church carrying them to the church.
And we were there for the mass meeting that night.
And when we went in, there were no whites.
When we sat there while the church was completely surrounded, as far as you could see,
white, mostly males on horses and carrying long guns and sitting outside waiting on us to come out.
And that was the night that we in fact spent the night at the church.
So it was a fear for night, but not enough fear to stop us from doing what we needed to do.
I was just going to say that Reverend Solomon S. Seay Sr said that night to me, we were eating some food, had come in, sandwiches, and that kind of thing.
And he was sitting on the steps at the church on the inside.
And I said, Reverend, say, what are we going to do?
Because as far as we could see, all these people surrounding us.
And he said, we're going to do like the doodle bird.
And I said, what do you mean?
He said, doodle bird?
Because he called me doodle bird quite a bit.
We're going to do like the doodle bird.
And I was an adult before I really understood what we were saying, but we played this game in Montgomery.
And we were seeing the doodle bird song.
And we said, back, back, doodle, back, back.
Your house is on fire.
Your children's burning.
Back, go back, doodle, back, back.
And I had to think about it as I became an adult because I really didn't know at the time what he was saying.
I thought about how that song said.
Your house is on fire and you're in trouble.
But you're going to be just like the doodle bird.
And the doodle bird, when we were singing that song, the doodle bird, with back,
just back out of the sand.
And he was so small, but as if to say, I'm protecting my own.
It's possible, excuse me, just one second.
We're back after short break.
Can you tell me about the founding of the Freedom Singers?
Well, actually, the Freedom Singers is, as you know them, I was not a part of that group.
I joined after leaving the Montgomery Gospel Trio.
But remember I went to school at Alabama State University so that we kept the group and so did the other two girls.
And so we kept the group going during the time that we were fighting for a voter registration and that kind of thing.
I may have mentioned that a lot of that was done by the youth because a lot of adults no longer wanted to participate for whatever their reasons were.
So when James Bevel and those people came into Montgomery, they called on us to sing before the meetings that we would have in the rural areas as well as in the city of Montgomery.
So we would travel around with them and we'd do the singing at the churches before the speech, of course, speak.
So we kept our group, the Montgomery Gospel Trio, going up until that time.
And after which I came to Atlanta, got with Bernice Johnson Reagon.
It started, I guess, I have to back up to say that.
She had asked that I participate in what they call the Pinnett Festival.
And that's where the community and the school that was so much separation that they had found this Pinnett Festival to come together with the community to put on a performance each year.
Yes, and I sneaked in that.
And when Bernice Johnson Reagon asked me to participate, we did the music for that first Pinnett Festival that we were doing.
And after, I say, goodness, I have them singing and this was so good to participate in that kind of thing.
But myself, along with another singer that was in the Harambee Singers, Matti Casey Pierce, Pierce Now, went to Bernice's house knocked on the door and said, we'd like to just continue to sing.
Let's continue to sing.
And thus far, we started the Harambee Singers.
So I wasn't in that freedom group singers with Bernice, but in the Harambee Singers with Harry.
Can you take you back?
Tell me about, I don't want to ask about repertoire and what she most liked to sing.
Like, saying the early in the gospel trio in Montgomery later in the, when you're college and then later with, how about that?
It depended on what was happening at the time.
That determined what we were seeing and what message we would, because we learned at Harlem that these songs, not only could care a message for the movement in Montgomery, but songs carry the message of the movement wherever.
And that when we went to Harlem, we would sing in our songs, this little light of mine, which became one of the famous songs of the movement.
And it's interesting to note that we were singing that for the movement at 11 years old and became one of the songs on the album there.
We did, but that was one of the important songs we got.
We are soldiers in the Army, was one of the songs we did, old freedom.
So we were doing all of these songs at 11 years old for the movement.
Songs which later became the bulk of the songs and the basis of the songs for that upcoming Civil Rights Movement.
What part did you sing?
I sang basically the melody, but we did interchange.
And I do a lot of the lead singing on the song, the verse singing.
Tell me about that work.
I think with about 66, 1966 forward, the Harambee singers, and tell me about how that group evolved and you work there.
I will.
I do want to say a bit more about how Linda and how our songs began to change as we attended those workshops with Guy Carawan and all.
If you go back to the songs, you will see that we were singing songs.
Basically, we didn't like the song.
There is a Montgomery song that represents that movement that was written by one of the professors at Alabama State.
For me, for that era was the first actual song that was written for movement.
And I like to get that in because people think it happened later on, but no right at that time.
He wrote that song.
But when we went to Highlander, we were singing some of the songs basically, the freedom songs basically as they were done traditionally.
And we are traditional singers.
And we would add a word in, in a verse or a line to represent our movement.
Or sometimes we would change a line.
But we weren't actually changing whole songs until actually we got there to Highlander and saw others do it.
And then we thought we were equipped.
We were going back then writing songs and doing our own version of the songs.
But we kept it traditional in terms of how we would sing the song.
So if you hear our album or any of those things, you will see we kept traditional ways of doing that.
If I wanted to add that because I wanted to get on the credit of how songs changed during the movement.
That kind of thing.
Now what happened?
In particular, what was that song that you wrote?
There's one song that you wrote?
He wrote Ain't Gonna Ride No Buses No More".
And it's interesting how he wrote that song, because sometimes now when I'm singing it, we are performing that song.
People look and say, did you all say hell?
Yes, that's the way he wrote the song.
Because he wrote it from a traditional song that I think that that song is Angerad no More.
And in that song it says, Highlander Hell, don't the white folks know we ain't going to ride them buses no More.
And he said, Highlander Hell, don't the white folk know we ain't going to write them buses no More.
I have read two different accounts for how you are credited with adding a very important verse to we shall overcome.
Can you share that to me with us?
You know what? I don't know how much light I can place on that because you have to remember that I was at Highlander when I was probably 14 years old.
And we weren't thinking at the time, oh I said this, I did this.
That was not upon our minds so that I can remember that when we went to Highlander, we had workshops to prepare us for different things that we would face.
And one of the things that Reverend Solomon S. Seay Sr who drove us there said to us is that we are going to leave by night.
And the reason for that is when you get into Monteagle and see the population of blacks, the population is just one.
And that was September clock.
And so to go in by night, we would not be noticed as we would go in.
So we went there by night and we came back by night.
But one of the things that happened when we were there is the policeman from the city came in.
We were having a movie I believe that night, a song's best.
And they came in, they turned out all the lights from the city, they turned them out.
So we were in complete darkness that night.
And we could not see each other, we didn't know where I didn't know where my sister was.
I didn't know where many were.
And we were just there, wherever we were at the time when the lights went out.
That's what we said.
And so all these policemen came in and all we could see basically is the billet club, weighted and the butts that are gone, you could see it shining.
And they told us to see if they could be quiet or whatever.
And something said, We Are Not Afraid" verse of We Shall Overcome.
And everybody started saying, we are not.
And you could hear people coming in.
My sister who is not a singer, I knew she was safe because I heard her out of tune voice coming in.
And I could hear men's bass coming, about We Are Not Afraid" verse of We Shall Overcome.
And we got louder and louder with singing that verse until one of the policemen came and he said to me,
if you have to sing and he was actually shaken, do you have to sing so loud?
And I could not believe it.
And all these people had all the guns, the billi-cups, the power we thought.
And he was asking me with a shake if I would not sing so loud.
And it was that time that I really understood the power of our music, how powerful it was that this it unnerved him so much that he had to come and ask that I not sing so loud.
And I could just tell you that I got louder and louder.
And somehow, even the nature out there in that darkness because everywhere was dark, but look like our voices blended that night to the point of complete harmony and beauty.
And from then on, I knew exactly how powerful our song was.
Can you tell a story about singing in a particular place that really stand at a moment in a place that stands out in your memory very good of the game?
Now, that stands out, but there are a number of them, but I can say that we were in Montgomery.
I was in college at the time.
And King was going to take us from his church.
He was no longer living at the time, but he had come back for, I can't even remember what the movement was all about.
And we were going to march to the capital in Montgomery.
And as we got to the top of the steps, and you saw all of these white people had, they had taken the mail to take it off their shirts, and they were just bare chested, standing up there with rifles and riding the horses.
And I saw, I faced these horses coming down on you.
And when I got to the top of the steps, it made me sing that verse again.
We Are Not Afraid" verse of We Shall Overcome, and we started singing it.
Now, I can tell you that my knees were actually shaking that day when I looked out to see all of them, and we were going to try to march to the capital.
But singing that song and that verse helped to count us steady those knees at that time.
And I can remember that particular verse at that time and that particular movement.
Tell me, let's just shift for just a moment.
And I'm interested in your experience in college.
Well, those college days were spent, as I said, SCLC had formed and sent James Bevel and James Orange into Montgomery.
And what we worked on at the time was voter registration again, even though I had handled voter registration at 12 years old with Mrs. Williams in Montgomery.
And during my high school days, we just continued that whole thing of going to Kings Hill.
We ventured out into other places besides Montgomery, because Montgomery was so tight at that time after having gone through that Montgomery bus boycott.
And the other thing we were working on was our sit-ins.
And so we would go to the church and plan as you with James Bevel and James Orange, how we were going to go to the five-and-dime stores.
And they told us at that time they had gone through training sessions on how to protect your head and that kind of thing and what happens if someone spits on you.
And so, really they taught us nonviolence to a great extent.
And so those were the kind of things that we worked on.
But let me just go back and say at 12 years old, in this Rosa Parks and Mrs. Williams, taught us how to fill out 27 page questionnaires.
So that we could go into the homes of adults and teach them how to fill out those questions to become voters.
That's what you had to do at the time.
Just silly, stupid kinds of questions.
We had to learn the Preamble to the Constitution.
But they set us on a little shop behind her house. She was our hairdresser.
And the youth would go in there and sit on the floor and learn how to fill out these at 11.
Fill out these and answer the questions.
And we would knock on doors and teach adults how to fill out.
By the mid-60s, the subarides act has passed, by the mid-60s, but there's been tremendous violence and difficulty.
And I'm thinking about the founding of the Harambee Singers.
And how did you perspective at that time, say, 66 maybe compared to your perspective earlier in the 60s,
or was your overall sense of feeling about the movement at that point in its progress and its challenges and its difficulties?
Personally, I started paying more attention to, I guess, what we call Black Power and the Pan-African Movement.
And so the songs that we performed as Harambee singers were what we call very radical type songs,
We'll Move On Over You".
And the songs took a different tone and became also international.
We were very in tune to our heritage at the time.
And as I said, Black Power.
And so when we went, our hair was afroating, this kind of thing.
And our songs took on some of that same mentality at the time.
So the Harambee singers song, we never did the songs that were performed by the Montgomery trio,
but in fact, Pan-Africanist type songs.
Can you tell me a little bit more about the groups repertoire?
In terms of the songs, Hands Off Nkrumah" was one of the songs that we did because at that time,
as I say, we had a Pan-Africanist perspective to what we were doing in the song.
And so that was important to us as the movement was going on in Ghana.
We did do that song of Hands Off Nkrumah".
That's what the people say, Hands Off Nkrumah".
And we talked about the CIA in the song.
So we started tacking other elements of not only this country, but the world and what was happening.
The things that want me to expand on things that already been said are just kind of things.
Don't you?
We've done pretty well.
I didn't want to go back.
Just ask about the question of whether or not your mother and your grandmother ever had to try to pull you and your sister
and brother back a little bit throughout a peer-free safety.
Is that a good question?
Yeah, but I'll start with our community and just say.
Okay, we've had a short break and we're going to come back and talk to the board about family and community.
Yes.
Our community was filled with people who had participated in struggle in some type way.
We had Flora Grant, who had one of the large debuts in Atlanta Life Insurance Company.
And who kept herself close to movement things that's happening in the community, who would come to my home and sit with my mother to talk about those things as I sat under the table and they played cards.
But I would hear a lot at that time because she was very knowledgeable as to the kind of current things happening in the Montgomery community.
So we had Flora Grant and we had the young lady who wrote, see how they run.
We had Sullivan Rogers, who was one of the first black jockeys.
And we saw him train his horses and he would tell us stories.
And we had my aunt who lived with us and her name we called her Besidee.
Now Besidee was the storyteller in my family and she would tell us about all kinds of struggles.
And the story that I remember from her was about the John".
And when she talked about the John", she said that he worked hard from son up to son down to take care of his family, of the family.
But at the end of the day or the week, he had no meat, he had very little food.
And it would bother him so much that he had taken care and raised the food for his owner as he sharecroped.
But he could not pay his bill at the end of the week.
And so the John" found ways to ever so often get his family to chicken.
And she told us the story of how John trained his younger son to come with him as they would get one chicken out of the white folks chicken coop.
And he said, John, this night I'm going to teach you how to prize.
And you're going to prize the chicken coop while I go on to get this one chicken.
Because there's something about black families that told them that they would get whatever was to survive but not more than that.
And so he would get this one chicken for his family.
So he carried a little John, I guess it was about the age of 12, I think she told us.
And they would get this long stick to pry up the chicken coop.
And this particular night, he was saying, Pry, boy".
As John was shaking and almost to drop the chicken coop before John could get the chicken from the chicken coop.
And he did with Pry, boy".
And my aunt was just shaking all over in her voice so she was telling us the story about Pry, boy".
And he dropped the chicken coop, could no longer hold it.
And John said, right boy, go tell your mama, you're going to lose your prize.
And so later on in life, from that story, I never forget that John could not feed his family,
working from son up to son down it.
Something in my hair did not set well with the fact that he couldn't feed his family.
And that story, so later on I wrote a song that says, Pry, boy".
Pry, boy".
Prize.
Run fast.
Go tell your mama, John to lose his prize.
So the people in the community, and as I say until young people, the song told us what you selected to do in life
will determine your life.
And I think it was the song told of these people.
And that impact on our lives that kept us even today, as I said here, 67 years old,
still involved in fighting for freedom.
So it's those kind of things.
And I tell even seeing it today, I work with seniors that we have to keep ourselves close to the young people,
causes the older people that had this impact in our lives that caused us to be the people that we are today.
Really want to thank you for joining us this moment. It's been a real pleasure to be with you.
Thank you.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.